You're First Lieutenant
Amanza Volchkova, right?
Yes, sir!
I took a hostage from the mining ship
I was a prisoner on,
and escaped.
I'll get the commander on the line.
Speak to him.
First Lieutenant Amanza.
Give me the details.
Tell me the location
of the illegal mining ship.
Yes, sir.
I would like you to use the IFN channel.
The die has been cast.
Come on now, boss!
The magnetic field
surrounding the ship is on.
Opening the bumpers to their maximum.
Clair. How long is left
until the maximal flare?
Based on Maya's predictions,
we have 15 minutes!
The 20 rounds is all that's left
from the Orichalt stock.
Prepare yourselves, kids!
Here we go!
So, when you escaped,
the illegal mining ship
was in the Regulus system
of the Leo constellation?
Yes, sir.
I'll check in with the
joint squadron command.
Until then, I'm putting you
under surveillance.
Do as you wish!
-Rick!
-All right!
-My fair lieutenant!
-Enough with familiarities!
-Do you want to die here?
-Oh, I apologize!
It's almost the time. Hurry up!
Shut up! I know.
Thirty-two seconds
until the Prominence launch.
Am I a criminal now, too?
It's time!
X line arcade confirmed!
Launching Prominence!
Orichalt's gravitational wave confirmed!
Orichalt's teleportation
confirmed!
Great, I'm in a Miguel jump, too.
Get lost!
Scouts 04, 05, pursue!
Battle regulations 03 permitted!
Don't let them get away!
Take care of this!
Gravitational waves detected!
Wh-- What did you say?!
Explosion!
Plasma particles detected!
Set the magnetic field!
-Shifting into emergency defense state!
-Joint search system has shut down!
Launching automated shielding.
Due to emergency, steering is impossible!
How could the fleet's squadron be fooled
by mere miners?!
My part here is done!
Now it's your turn, Ido!